come together mostly made once again to
get to clean water families in gaza 105
pounds can provide
interrupted water to two families for an
entire year
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum today better care to
you brothers and sisters and dear
friends before i start one piece i lost
a panel with all of the most merciful
the most trust or praise his glory and
gratitude belong to him
robin says ben and jerry has made a
profound move so much so that israel and
his prime minister the scum dirtbag the
terrorists
yes the one who was killing innocent
people in apartheid state
has lost his mind the guy has gone crazy
here's what ben and jerry has to say
so ben and jerry said ben and jerry's
will end sales of our ice cream in
occupied occupied you know we know you
hate that
israeli prime minister if you're
watching this you might happen to or the
idea of
you know i'm sure you guys are watching
this die in your rage
in occupied palestinian territory now
this is an ice cream they sell ice cream
they chose not to sell
ice cream in the occupied lands in that
specific palestinian
area where hollow of palestine is
occupied um but
israel pm warns that's really the bbc
news here let me trust people soon as
well let's read this anyways
israel pm warns ben and jerry's owner
unilever
of consequences over sales of ban
consequences for not selling ice cream
not relax yourself man personally like a
person like the chocolate fudge brownie
yeah um i i i didn't buy it
because of this but now i might be
buying some you know even though
nominated for diet
israel israel's prime minister will take
strong action against boycotts after ben
and jerry's decided to stop selling
ice cream in israel settlements in the
occupied palestinian territories i mean
can you imagine this
you're oppressing a group of people
apartheid state terrorist state and you
have a problem because a company comes
and says
we don't agree with that and you're i
think we're selling it in stolen land
and we've decided that it doesn't go
with our values and you're like oh
all right okay we're going to take
strong action and nobody wants to talk
about this the far right
everyone's quiet about it anyways let's
carry on
uh naftali bennett may allah curse him
they wanted the u.s firm's parents
company univer
u.s firms parent company you warned um
them
unilever that there would be legal and
other consequences ben and jerry said on
monday that the sale of its products in
the west bank and east jerusalem was
increasing
inconsistent with our values palestinian
activists praised the move
more than 600 000 jews living about 140
settlements built
since israel's occupation of the west
bank and is jerusalem in the 1967 middle
east war
most of the international community
considers the settlements illegal on the
international law
though israel disputes this i mean it's
unbelievable the international law says
it's
you're stealing land and they're like no
we're not can you imagine a thief
telling you
no i'm not stealing but law says you are
no but i don't think i
i am anyways the bbc's tom bat
batman in jerusalem says ben and jerry's
is probably in israel it's ice cream to
come in special flavors to mark jewish
festivals or national events
national events uh well they don't want
to sell it because you guys are thieves
anyways it is also sold in israeli
settlements something that has been
activists
has seen activists in the u.s put
pressure on the company known for its
progressive views
mr bennett said he spoke to he has
spoken to the unilever ceo allen job
about the clearly anti-israel step
i mean we kill we steal and if you don't
want to sell products in the stolen
lands that's full of blood of the
palestinians
you know um that's a clearly anti-israel
step you are anti-semitic
get the hell out of here you little punk
coward taken by the uk based consumer
goods
giant subsidiary this is an action that
has severe consequences
including legal and israel will take
strong action against any boycott
boycott directly against the citizens
they fear boycott so much
that is their worst nightmare because
they know that ended apartheid
in south africa but inshallah is coming
and this is exactly what happened at the
prophet peace be upon him time when he
was 20 years old it was helpful for
a man was oppressed unjustly he his
goods were taken and he did not get in
uh he was not paid for it and he asked
for
the help injustice he sought injustice
and the prophet peace be upon him this
is before islam
he went there and stuck up for his
rights
yes that's what allah says
yeah so come together in righteousness
here so against oppression
so as you can see that the prophet
peace be upon him narrated and hadith
that he said if this was to happen
while as a muslim as islam has come i
would have done the same thing
islam sticks by injustice even if he's
joining
pagans arabs yeah even if he's joining
them against it
inshallah israel's foreign minister yair
lapid called ben and jerry's move a
disgraceful capitulation
to anti-semitism and boycott divestment
and sanctions bds movement
which calls for a complete boycott of of
israeli of his treatment of the
palestinians
look at that it makes classic sense how
youtube palestinians should be boycotted
damn right
he said he would ask the 35 u.s
u.s states with anti-bds laws to enforce
them
against the company look at this threat
you look at
these guys who the hell do you think you
guys are yeah
bds called ben and jerry's decision a
decisive step towards ending the
companies
complicit complicity in israel's
occupation and violation of
palestinian human rights my gosh
can you imagine an ice cream a mere ice
cream company
stopping selling their goods because of
the oppression they see
and these guys the prime minister how
could you stop that
over an ice cream yeah over an ice cream
and this shows you
how scared they are and they know the
public opinion israel
is taking a massive u-turn and ben and
jerry and more other companies are going
to come
carry on this movement so much so that
they're threatening them with using 35
states
uh in america um to basically do some
kind of sanctions towards them
well uh the prime minister of israel
bite your hand out of rage
die out of your rage yeah you are a
killing
terrorist state yeah you are a terrorist
state that has the 66 blood
of muslims palestinian children kids
just this ramadan yeah and may allah
destroy you in this life and in the
hereafter the whole world can see
your hands are full of blood till next
time brothers and sisters
i think i'm going to go and buy a ben
jerry's ice cream maybe a
a chocolate fudge brownie you know
because i think the prime minister
uh the new uh blood uh thirsty
uh prime minister uh has done a bit of a
brownie himself and i'm not talking
about a chocolate one you know
uh yeah maybe we need to change his
nappies until next time hope you enjoyed
this video share with your friends and
family